après le vélo de remet le Golf National
c'est au tour du stade de BMX de 50 ans
en Yvelines d'accueillir la tournée des
sites olympiques juste ici derrière moi
les athlètes de Paris 2024 se
disputeront la médaille d'or du BMX Race
ce sera le premier et le 2 août et on va
vous faire revivre cette soirée qui
s'est déroulé le jeudi 11 mai c'est
parti
[Musique]
et pour cette tournée des sites
olympiques bien sûr des officiels qui
sont présents et notamment Aurélie merle
bonjour bonjour vous êtes la directrice
exécutive des sports pour le comité
d'organisation de Paris 2024 juste déjà
en quoi consiste la tournée des sites
olympiques quelles sont les objectifs de
ces rendez-vous alors l'objectif
d'attendre et des sites c'est de faire
connaître les sites olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 à des gens
qui étaient sélectionnés vla le club le
Club de Paris 2024 donc c'est Jean
peuvent venir
connaître un peu les sites rencontrer
des grands champions se frotter un petit
peu à leur discipline et ça permet en
fait de créer ce lien entre le grand
public et les Jeux Olympiques l'objectif
de Paris 2024 c'est que ce soit un
maximum ouvert aux gens c'est c'est les
Jeux Olympiques des Français aussi
finalement exactement en fait notre
slogan c'est ouvrons grand les jeux donc
on a vraiment envie de faire qui est une
osmose entre le grand public et les jeux
de paris 2024 il y a eu beaucoup
d'incertitudes d'ailleurs sur cette
piste de BMX il avait été év un temps de
faire les épreuves sur l'île de loisirs
qui est juste à côté il lui aussi la
question de ce toit qui est semblait-il
été problématique est-ce que tout est
réglé sur le dossier du BMX en vue des
JO oui tout à fait
et le site qui accueillera en 2024 donc
les épreuves de BMX race on travaille à
la fois que la Fédération Internationale
donc lui ci et l'ensemble des parties
prenantes pour faire que ce soit une
vraie réussite en 24 et donc là il y a
des initiations il y a aussi un échange
direct avec les athlètes on renonvient à
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur
l'ouverture des des jeux de pouvoir
aussi échanger avec ses athlètes qui
sont peut-être sur sur la piste de BMX
en 2027 c'est aussi important exactement
c'est à dire que là ils vont pouvoir et
c'est ce qui est assez génial c'est
lancé se mettre dans la peau d'un
athlète qui le premier de août 2024 vont
s'élancer sur cette piste de BMX et mon
pouvoir aussi comprendre un petit peu à
quoi correspondent leur sport comprendre
leur prouesses techniques donc c'est
c'est c'est une expérience unique pour
ces 24 personnes qui ont été
sélectionnées via le club il y aura
d'autres rendez-vous sera la dernière
question d'autres tournées est-ce que
c'est déjà prévu ce que le calendrier
déjà été alors il y en aura d'autres
mais on n'a pas encore les détails on
reviendra vers vous avec plus
d'informations et justement olymère elle
disait qu'il y avait des athlètes
présents on va aller dans quelques
instants à la tête mais juste avant on
va écouter Jean-Michel fourgousse le
président de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines justement pour
voir comment l'agglomération se prépare
aussi à recevoir cet événement des Jeux
Olympiques ben ça montre que c'est parti
les Américains let's go bref c'est voilà
l'action voilà c'est on construit alors
on construit avec tous les partenaires
c'est c'est faut voir que il y a des
très bons partenaires privés publics
très actif donc voilà et puis bien sûr
tous les associations sportives il y a
surtout la colline d'Élancourt qui est
en train d'être finaliser après il va y
avoir un crash test qui va être fait en
septembre on va tester les quatre six
avec toutes les hypothèses voilà du bien
mesurer les problèmes de sécurité et les
problèmes mais sur d'accès
voilà et puis les conditions pour
recevoir autant de gens différents parce
que c'est multiculturelle ce jour-là
donc voilà on se prépare à tout ça on se
forme et tout le monde est heureux
l'équipe bien sûr être heureuse de
participer à un tel événement c'est
c'est hors norme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour cette tournée des sites
olympiques ici sur ce Stadium de BMX de
50 ans Nîmes bien sûr des athlètes de la
team France qui sont présents notamment
léogare Royan bonjour Léo bonjour et
sans champion du monde de U23 c'était
lors des championnats du monde qui se
déroulaient à Nantes l'été dernier tout
simplement déjà de faire découvrir votre
discipline à des personnes qui ont été
sélectionnées qui font partie du club
Paris 2024 est-ce que c'est intéressant
d'échanger avec eux pour vous bah oui
c'est toujours intéressant je pense même
pour la plupart des personnes de
découvrir de nouveaux sports c'est vrai
que notre sport c'est de plus en plus
médiatisé mais ça reste quand même très
exceptionnel de regarder de voir de
d'apprendre un peu plus comment ça
fonctionne donc c'est avec des personnes
qui ont été sélectionnées qui sont là
vraiment pour tous les sports qui
peuvent apprendre un peu tous les sports
c'est vrai que découvrir de nouveaux
sports et encore plus notre sport qui
est quand même assez exceptionnel c'est
vrai que ça reste quand même quelque
chose de de chouette à faire quoi les
épreuves ici on se déroulé les premiers
et deux août c'est une opportunité
incroyable vous le disiez d'avoir ces JO
ici sur sur le sol français justement
pour mettre en lumière aussi
la discipline peut être aussi pour avoir
un peu plus de chance à domicile de
remporter des médailles bah oui je pense
que de toute façon les Jeux Olympiques
ça reste exceptionnel mais encore plus
en France se dire qu'on peut faire les
Jeux Olympiques en France après c'est
sûr que c'est dans longtemps mais en
même temps c'est demain donc il reste
encore pas mal de chemin et des tapes à
passer avant d'être Jeux Olympiques donc
on va prendre notre temps on va pas se
presser mais c'est vrai qu'avoir les
jeux en France et encore plus bah là du
coup à Saint-Quentin parce qu'on est sur
la piste olympique sur laquelle il va se
dérouler les Jeux Olympiques ça reste
encore plus plus exceptionnel surtout
que ben nous on vient on s'entraîne ici
et pour le moment je pense on réalise
pas que les Jeux Olympiques dans dans un
an un peu plus d'un an c'est ici et ça
va se dérouler ici et la médaille d'or
elle va se poser ici quoi et pour un
sportif quand on parle de jeux
olympiques ça représente quoi pour vous
quand je vous dis Jeux Olympiques moi je
pense c'est le Graal absolu c'est fait
un peu comme dans les autres sports pour
moi je compare un peu les Jeux
Olympiques autour de France aux cyclisme
mais il faut se dire que ça reste qu'une
course et
les adversaires on les connaît c'est
pareil quoi
récemment sur le sol français alors des
championnats du monde qui se déroulaient
à Nantes un titre de champion du Monde
du 23 de BMX Racing c'est un objectif
réel pour vous atteignable c'est Jeux
Olympiques en France bah oui après
est-ce que ça atteignable là je sais pas
encore disons que je vais tout faire
pour y arriver je vais pas me mettre de
limites parce que je pense que ça sert à
rien de se mettre des limites après je
suis encore jeune pour les Jeux
Olympiques à Paris mais disons que je
vais tout faire je vais tout essayer
pour me qualifier pour essayer d'être
aux Jeux Olympiques à Paris disons que
j'ai pas de limite encore fixé pure et
dur mais c'est vrai que ouais ça reste
ça reste un grand challenge et une
grande étape pour moi d'aller aux Jeux
olympiques et de ramener une médaille
merci Léo et je vous le disais tout à
l'heure aux côtés des athlètes justement
pour faire ces initiations les membres
du club Paris 2024 on va aller leur
poser quelques questions et ça vous fait
quoi de découvrir ce site olympique du
Stadium de BMX et de pouvoir découvrir
et s'initier la discipline bah c'est
très excitant car j'avais jamais fait de
BMX de ma vie j'avais déjà vu à la télé
mais c'est c'est super cool de pouvoir
essayer on a des bonnes sensations et
c'est franchement agréable salut BMX
c'est super physique c'est vachement
drôle il y a plein de sensations dès le
départ on dirait pas comme ça on peut
d'alpa mais ça fatigue quand même ça
fait bien chauffer les cuisses pas du
tout dans le dans le vélo de base donc
c'est quelque chose que je découvre et
c'est très plaisant plus on découpe le
vélodrome aussi j'étais jamais venu au
Vélodrome donc toujours très sympa
[Musique]
voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire sur
cette tournée des sites olympiques je
vous rappelle qu'à 50 ans en Yvelines il
y a 4 sites des épreuves de Paris 2024
la piste de BMX bien sûr derrière moi le
vélo drone national de 50 ans divine
juste à côté mais aussi le Golf National
a Guyancourt et la colline d'Élancourt
ou en ce moment même se déroule des
travaux en vue de ces Jeux Olympiques on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir dans le 7 8